ever had this type of project for our
children local authorities are already
setting out their plans for this
christmas and let's make sure that we
get to even more kids hey reeves thank
you mr speaker over the past decade
there's been a 47 decrease in drama and
a 36 drop in music participation in
schools a broad curriculum is vital to
young people's life chances yet access
often depends on parents ability to pay
for these activities i heard what the
minister had to say about the music
curriculum but unless the government
commits to providing the resources to
all schools to provide creative arts
education young people will be let down
what will the minister do about it will
you provide that funding finished
i've committed to arts education the
proportion taking at least one
gcse in an art subject has remained
broadly stable over the last 10 years
and also we're committed to very
significant sums of of funding for arts
and music projects 620
million pounds over the last uh three
years including um 79 million pounds for
the 119 music education hubs 148 million
pounds for the music and dance scheme we
are very committed
to the arts and to drama in our schools
thank you mr speaker will the secretary
of state kindly speak with the secretary
of state for the home department about
getting visas
[Applause]
about getting visas for the 12 at-risk
afghan scholars some still in hiding
some in pakistan who have been awarded
sponsored places by
high quality british universities and
need the visas to take them up
i will most certainly undertake to do
that and i think we've seen the
education community in the united
kingdom coming together in order to
support those who want to resettle from
afghanistan here in this country but i
will certainly undertake that and we
also want to look at the opportunities
for those brilliant amazing people from
afghanistan and other opportunities they
can play in our part in the education
system here in the uk
we now come to the statement on
afghanistan from the prime minister
prime minister thank you
thank you uh mr speaker with your
permission i will update the house on
the situation in afghanistan
and our enduring effort to provide
sanctuary for those to whom we owe so
much
since the house last met our armed
forces diplomats and civil servants have
completed the biggest and fastest
emergency evacuation in recent history
overcoming every possible challenge in
the most harrowing conditions and
bringing 15 000 people to safety in the
uk and helping 36 36 other countries
airlift their own nationals
they faced the pressure of a remorseless
deadline and witnessed a contemptible
terrorist attack at the very gates of
the airport with two british nationals
and 13 of our american allies among the
dead
but they kept going and in the space of
a fortnight they evacuated our own
nationals alongside afghan friends of
this country who guided translated and
served with our soldiers and officials
proving their courage and loyalty beyond
that
sometimes in the heat of battle
the whole house will join me in
commending the courage and ingenuity of
everyone involved in the kabul airlift
one of the most spectacular operations
in our country's post-war military
history this feat
exemplified the spirit of all the 150
000 british servicemen and women who
deployed in afghanistan over the last
two decades
of whom 457 laid down their lives and
many others suffered trauma and injury
thanks to their efforts
no terrorist attack against this country
or any of our western allies has been
launched from afghanistan for 20 years
they fulfilled the first duty of the
british armed forces to keep our people
safe and they and their families
should take pride in everything they did
just as they kept us safe so we shall do
right by our veterans in addition to the
extra three million pounds we've
invested in mental health support
through nhs of courage we're providing
another five million pounds to assist
military charities who do such
magnificent work with the aim of
ensuring that no veteran's request for
help will go unanswered
and now
the evacuation of pitting will give way
to operation warm welcome with an equal
effort to help our afghan friends begin
their new lives here in the united
kingdom
and recognizing the strength of feeling
across the house about the plight of
individual afghans
years before this episode we began to
fulfill our obligation to those afghans
who had helped us bringing 1
400 to the uk
then in april this year we expanded our
efforts by opening the afghan
relocations and assistance policy and
even before the onset of operation
pitting we'd brought around 2000 to the
uk between june and august and our
obligation lives on
so let me say to anyone to whom we've
made commitments and who is currently in
afghanistan
we are working urgently with our friends
in the region to secure safe passage and
as soon as routes are available we will
do everything possible to help you to
reach safety
over and above this effort the uk is
formally launching a separate a separate
resettlement program
providing a safe and legal route for up
to 20 000 afghans in the region over the
coming years with 5 000 in the first
year we are upholding britain's finest
tradition of welcoming those in need and
i emphasize that under this scheme we
will of course work with the un and aid
agencies to identify those we should
help as we have done in respect of those
who fled the war in syria
but we will also
include afghans who have contributed to
civil society or who face a particular
risk from the taliban for example
because of their role in standing up for
democracy
and human rights
or because of their gender or sexuality
or religion
all who come to our country through this
safe and legal route will receive not a
five-year visa
but indefinite leave to remain
and our support will include free
english courses for adults and 300
university scholarships
we will shortly be writing to local
authorities and the devolved
administrations with details on funding
for extra school places and long-term
accommodation across the uk
i'm grateful for everything they are
doing and of course for the work of my
honourable friend the minister for
afghan resettlement yeah
i'm i'm aware of that
i'm i'm delighted but not surprised that
across our country people have been
fundraising for our afghan friends
and we've received numerous offers of
help from charities and ordinary
families alike
and anyone who wishes to join that
effort can do so through gov dot uk
mr speaker our first duty is to the
security of the united kingdom
and if the new regime in kabul wants
international recognition and access to
the billions of dollars currently frozen
in overseas accounts then we and our
friends will hold them
to their agreement to prevent
afghanistan from ever again becoming an
incubator for terrorism and we shall
insist on safe passage for anyone who
wishes to leave
and respect for the rights of women and
girls
our aim is to rally the strongest
international consensus behind these
principles so that as far as possible
the world speaks to the taliban with one
voice to that end i called an emergency
meeting of the g7 leaders which made
these aims the basis of our common
approach
and the uk helped us secure a u.n
resolution passed by the security
council last week making the same
demands
later this month at the un general
assembly in new york i'll work with the
un secretary general guterres and other
leaders to widen that consensus still
further
we will judge the taliban
by their
actions not their words
and use every economic political and
diplomatic lever to protect our own
countries from harm
and to help the afghan people we've
already doubled the uk's humanitarian
and development assistance to 286
million pounds this year including
including to help people in the region
mr speaker
on saturday
on saturday we shall mark the 20th
anniversary
of the reason why we went into
afghanistan in the first place
the terrorist attacks on the united
states which claimed 2977
lives including those of 67
britons
and if anyone
is tempted to say
that we have achieved nothing in that
country or still tempted to say mr
speaker we have achieved nothing in that
country in 20 years
tell them that our armed forces and
those of our allies enabled 3.6 million
girls to go to school
tell them that this country and the
western world were protected from
al-qaeda in afghanistan throughout that
period
and tell them mr speaker that we have
just mounted the biggest humanitarian
airlift in recent history eight times
the raf rescued more than 400 people on
board a single plane the most that have
ever traveled on an raf aircraft in its
103 year history
helping thousands of people in fear for
their lives helping thousands to whom
this country owes so much
and thereby revealing the fundamental
values of the united kingdom
there are very few countries that have
the military capability to do what we
have just done
and fewer still that would have felt the
moral imperative to act in the same way
we can be proud of our armed forces and
everything they have achieved and for
the legacy they leave behind and what
they did
was in the best traditions of this
country and i commend this statement to
the house
leaving the opposition dear starbuck
uh thank you mr speaker and thank you to
the prime minister for advanced copy of
his statement
the heroes on the ground of operation
pitting are the best of us
the ambassador stayed to process every
case that he could
paratroopers lifted people from the
crush
afghan soldiers continued to serve
alongside us to the end
and thousands of others risk their lives
to help others escape
they face deadly violence and
deliberately engineered chaos
with courage
with calm
and with determination
thanks to their remarkable efforts
thousands were evacuated
british nationals have returned safely
to their families
and afghan friends are starting a new
life here in britain
speaking directly to those who served in
operation pitting
i say thank you
your service deserves recognition and
honor
and i hope that the prime minister will
accept labour's proposal to scrap the
30-day continuous service rule so that
medals are awarded for your bravery
the entire army
our armed forces and veterans deserve
proper support for mental health the new
funding announced today is welcome
but it's unlikely to be enough
previous funding was described mr
speaker as scandalous by the select
committee and the office for veterans
affairs is still being cut
all those involved deserved political
leadership equal to their service
but they were let down
they were let down on strategy
the prime minister underestimated the
strength of the taliban
despite intelligence warnings that rapid
taliban advances could lead to the
collapse of the afghan securities forces
a return to power of the taliban and our
embassy shutting down amid reduced
security
the government continued to act on the
assumption
that there was no path to military
victory for the taliban
complacent
and wrong
they were let down mr speaker by lack of
planning
18 months passed between the doha
agreement and the fall of kabul
yet as the prime minister now concedes
only
000 of the 8 000 people eligible for the
arab scheme had been brought to britain
2 000 of 8 000.
a strategic review was published to much
fanfare but it didn't mention the
taliban nato withdrawal or the doha
agreement and the prime minister only
convened a g7 meeting on
afghanistan after kabul was lost
because of this lack of leadership the
government has left many behind to whom
we owe so much
mps in the last few weeks
have had thousands of desperate calls
from people trying to get to safety
many remain in danger
including the afghan guards who
predicted protected the british embassy
in my constituency and i'm not alone
members across the house would have had
this
afghans who applied for the arab scheme
weeks ago sometimes months ago who were
clearly eligible
but weren't processed quickly enough by
this government
didn't make it to the plains
and the stress levels of them and their
families and all of our
teams
and caseworkers has been palpable in the
last few weeks and months a familiar and
desperate story to many across this
house on both sides
the government doesn't even know how
many uk nationals and how many afghans
eligible eligible under the arab scheme
have been left behind to the cruelty of
the taliban
a national disgrace
even if they could identify who they'd
left behind the government doesn't have
a plan to get everybody out
kabul airport remains closed to
international flights
safe passage has not been created to
afghans neighbors and whatever the prime
minister says today there is no
international agreement on the
resettlement of afghan refugees
we have a prime minister incapable of
international leadership
just when we needed it
i know it's uncomfortable
the terrible attacks from isis k
highlight the new security threat
the government must act quickly to
coordinate international partners to
ensure the afghan government's collapse
does not lead to a vacuum for terrorists
to fill and there's a desperate need for
humanitarian support the return to 2019
levels of aid spending is necessary and
where's the plan to ensure it doesn't
fall into the wrong hands
mr speaker to those that have managed to
escape afghanistan and have arrived here
in the uk
we say welcome
i know you will give as much to this
country as you make it your new home
all you need is help and support and i'm
pleased that indefinite leave to remain
will now be granted to all those who
arrive by safe and legal routes
local authorities across the country are
trying to play their part
but they've been in the dark as to how
many people they'll be asked to support
what resources they will have to do so
so we will look at the details we will
look at the details of the letter the
prime minister referred to and examine
the details
history will tell
the tale of operation pitting
as one of immense bravery
we are proud of all those who
contributed
their story made even more remarkable
by the fact that whilst they were saving
lives
our political leadership
was missing in action
[Music]
uh well mr speaker though there weren't
any questions that the right honourable
gentleman put to me uh in that he made
the general assertion that uh the
government hadn't been focusing on on
afghanistan but he as well as i can
remember he didn't even bother to turn
up to the first of the three statements
i've given on afghanistan uh in this
house mr speaker uh this year i don't
know where i don't know where he was
such with his instincts and such with
his understanding of the importance of
that issue i can tell him mr speaker
that actually his figures are quite
wrong uh that before april we we helped
uh 1400 uh people uh to safety from
afghanistan uh under the arap scheme
since april in april and august the 14th
we helped a further 2000 and then as he
knows very well uh mr speaker between
august the 14th and august uh the 28th
this country performed an absolutely
astonishing feat of uh and yes yes of
course yes of course the yes of course
mr speaker we are going to do everything
we can to help those who wish to have a
safe passage out of afghanistan and we
were and that is why we will continue uh
with our international friends and
partners to apply whatever pressure uh
we can economic diplomatic uh on the tel
on the taliban uh to ensure that they uh
they comply with that mr speaker as they
have said uh that they will but mr
speaker it is i think the right
honourable gentleman should in all
canada uh acknowledge the immensity of
the achievement of the armed forces of
this country in in planning in planning
and preparing for months
for months of operation pitting mr
speaker and then and then mr speaker
contrary to what he has just said
extracting almost double almost double
the number that they originally
preparing to do it is a quite
astonishing
feat it is a quite astonishing military
and logistic feat and uh one thing i
welcome uh mr speaker one thing i
welcome is his congratulations to the
armed forces for what they did
tobias
thank you mr speaker veterans and
families indeed the wider public are
asking what was it all for
the country
is back in the hands of dictatorship
terrorism is once again allowed to
thrive and the people of afghanistan now
face humanitarian disaster more
worryingly the limits of the uk and
western influence have been exposed and
with america now adopting a more
isolationist foreign policy we have
passed the high watermark of western
liberalism that began after the second
world war this is a dangerous
geopolitical turning point i asked the
prime minister would he agree there is
now a void of leadership in the west and
nato and if britain wants to fill that
void as we should do it will require a
complete overhaul of whitehall to
upgrade our strategic thinking our
foreign policy output and our ability to
lead
uh mr speaker i i the my right animal
friend uh deserves to listen to his
great respect on uh afghanistan and for
his uh service he understands these
issues deeply but i must i must tell him
that i think people listening to this
debate across the country uh could be
forgiven for and not recognizing this
country actually ceased military
operations in afghanistan in 2014
and uh what we are doing now is making
sure that we work with our friends and
partners around the world to prevent
afghanistan from relapsing into a
breeding ground for terror to make sure
that we use all the levers that we can
to ensure that the
rights of women and girls are respected
and that everybody who wants safe
passage out of afghanistan is is allowed
to do that that is what we're going to
do and we will continue to show the
leadership that we have in the g7 in the
p5 uh in nato and all the other forums
in which this country uh leads the west
in blackford the leader of the smp
thank you mr speaker and can i thank all
those assisted in the evacuation from
afghanistan over the last few weeks then
can i thank the prime minister for
advanced copy of his statement
mr speaker
normally we have a cabinet minister sent
to the house to cover for the prime
minister
but today
we have before us the prime minister
desperately trying to cover for a
foreign secretary who should have been
sacked weeks ago
during committee last week
the foreign secretary failed to answer
even basic questions from my honorable
friend the member for glasgow south i
generally hope that the prime minister
is better prepared today
mr speaker there is barely an mp in this
house who hasn't submitted urgent and
sensitive information to the foreign
office on uk and afghan nationals
desperate to find safe passage away from
the taliban it is a disgrace that most
of these urgent queries have been left
unresolved and unanswered a disgrace
not for us
but for all those who have been left
behind uk and afghan nationals who are
now fearful and in many cases in hiding
thousands of desperate people people we
have a debt of responsibility to have
been left with no clarity
no answers and no help
so let me ask the prime minister what
assessment has been made of the number
of uk nationals left in afghanistan and
what plans are there to assist them
how many afghans that qualify under the
arab scheme as interpreters or in other
groups who have been left behind and
will the prime minister apologize to
those who have been left behind left
high and dry those that the uk has a
responsibility to
last night
in correspondence from lord ahmed the
government gave the excuse
that delays in evacuating all those with
rights were because the foreign office
had received more correspondence than
during covid
but mr speaker there is a fundamental
difference
no one knew covid was coming the
government had 18 months
18 months to prepare an exit strategy in
afghanistan so can the prime minister
give a firm deadline when the massive
backlog of applications will be
processed and provide a new target date
for when safe passage will be offered to
those uk and afghan citizens when
parliament was recalled the prime
minister publicly agreed to hold a four
nation summit on the uk's responsibility
to welcome refugees here can i ask the
prime minister to give us the date when
that summit will take place and finally
with all the talk of cabinet reshuffle
can the prime minister guarantee that
the foreign secretary will finally be
sacked in any reshuffle or does he
intend to reward incompetence
always uh mr speaker happy to uh meet
representatives of the of the scottish
government and other devolved
administrations of course uh mr speaker
but uh he asked some specific questions
about uh the uh the the handling of
requests from uh those still in
afghanistan i can uh and those who've
been interceding on their behalf i can
tell him that uh by close of play today
every single one of the emails from
colleagues around this house uh will be
answered uh and the thousands and
thousands have already been done and as
for
and as for the question mr speaker of
how many arap how many arap candidates
uh are remaining i can tell him that the
total number is
311 uh of which 192 uh responded to the
calls that were that were put out and i
repeat mr speaker we will do absolutely
everything we can to ensure that those
people get the safe passage that they
deserve using the the levers that i have
described but nothing about the contrast
mr speaker should be readily apparent to
everybody in this country uh with a huge
number 15 000 people that we were able
to help just in the course of those few
days in august i think people will
understand that it was a very
considerable effort by our armed forces
just out the house we'll be running this
to around 4 45. not everybody's going to
get in people will be disappointed but
we're going to do our best so let's help
each other theresa may
i join my right honourable friend in
commending all those involved with the
afghanistan airlift and also all those
of our armed forces who served in
afghanistan sadly 457 of whom as we know
paid the ultimate sacrifice
we should all be proud of their
achievements
does my right honourable friend agree
that as a result of nato forces
withdrawing from afghanistan the
terrorist threat has increased and will
he confirm that all those involved in
counter-terrorism work here in the uk
will be given the necessary to support
to ensure they can keep us safe
thank my right honourable friend and i
know how much work she has done in her
career to protect this country uh and to
assist the encounter terrorism mr
speaker i can give her note that i we
have no direct information as yet of any
increase to the uh to the threat mr
speaker but i can assure her and the
house uh that every effort uh will be
made to make sure that uh our
counter-terrorist uh agents have the uh
resources they need to keep us safe
mr speaker i've received hundreds of
emails from constituents about
afghanistan and i have british nationals
in afghanistan a husband and his
pregnant wife
can the prime minister say what
discussions the government has had with
afghanistan neighbours about keeping
borders open for those at risk under the
taliban and to support refugees
prime minister thank you very much i'm
sure that many colleagues around the
house will be asking similar questions i
can i can tell her that my right-hand
friend the foreign secretary has been
talking to the government in pakistan
and other regional uh countries about uh
what we can do to
assist them as i've as i've described
and uh as she knows uh we have in
addition to the arap program uh we have
the afghan uh settlement uh program uh
running up to two to twenty thousand
over the next few years
thank you mr speaker may i first of all
pay tribute to the prime minister for
his increased uh funding towards mental
health care for veterans and i'm sure
he's going to keep that some under
review should it need to rise may i ask
him however if he'll draw the lesson
that he's already learned from the
appointment of our right of a friend the
member for laugh and horn castle in
having a single point of contact in the
uk and seek to have a single point of
contact for those in afghanistan who may
need to access either the route of exit
or support from her majesty's government
prime minister
uh yes mr speaker i i i thank the
honourable general he knows where all he
speaks and i've i've met uh uh people
who've come uh from afghanistan only
recently who have helped us greatly in
the last 20 years and the key issues for
them as the house will understand are
where are they going to send their their
children to to school uh can they get
access to the housing they need i want
to thank my right on offender uh
secretary of state communities and local
government for what he's doing and uh
and he is quite right mr speaker uh that
uh my uh honorable friend the member for
life in horn castle is the single point
of contact uh that they should uh focus
upon and davey mr speaker we all saw the
horrific carnage outside kabul airport
over 180 people killed so i joined the
prime minister in remembering all those
victims not least the two british
nationals and the child of a british
national
that airport atrocity
was the work of the terrorist
organization isis k
everyone agrees it must now work to stop
isis k becoming a threat to the british
people
yet under this prime minister's watch
not only has he failed to agree an
international coordinator strategy to
take on isis k
he's even failed to prescribe isis k as
a terrorist organization unlike other
five eye countries
will the prime minister explain these
failures on national security
i i'm afraid the right arm of gentleman
is is in error i i isis k uh isis
khorasan province is a is a subset of uh
of daesh it's part of the it's part of
daesh and as as he knows very well uh
they uh
one of the one of the bitter ironies of
the situation is of course that the
taliban themselves are no friends uh to
isis k and uh and and
whatever government there is in in kabul
uh will need help fighting them jacob
speaker we are proving our immense
generosity by supporting those in dire
need in afghanistan with safe passage to
the uk but our ability to do so is
strained by the continuing uncontrolled
illegal migration on the english channel
what more can the government do to
prevent it
my my honorable friend is uh is
completely right and of course the uh
the issue is that that uh very sadly i
think uh uh our our friends across the
uh across the channel in france uh are
faced with a very difficult problem of
large numbers of people who uh who want
to come to this country and
we are doing everything that we can to
encourage uh
the french to do the necessary and
impede their their passage but i know
that my right arm will friend the home
secretary is working around the clock to
ensure that we not only encourage the
french to stiffen their uh their sinews
and stop people making the journey but
we use every possible tactic that is
available to us as well john mcdonald
can i ask the prime minister
raise a constituency matter with the
prime minister
um
i've had over 800 afghani local families
contact me about their concerns about
their relatives in afghanistan and we
now have the thousands that are coming
to this country largely coming through
heathrow and being quarantined in about
seven hotels in my constituency
there's a real anxiety that on past
performance of what's happened with
asylum seekers in hotels in our
constituency they could be trapped in
those hotels for quite a long time to
come
what i'd like the minister to arrange is
for a meeting with myself and the
relevant minister officials to discuss
the plan
for the support for those families
because i welcome like everybody else
and my community does to the support for
those families but also the long-term
relocation plan to make sure that they
have all that they can to settle here
for the future
thank you mr speaker well the right
honourable gentleman uh is right to draw
attention to the the issue uh some
councils have responded magnificently uh
notably in the east midlands and uh and
elsewhere uh i know that uh my normal
friend is putting uh for us for clg is
putting substantial funding uh in place
uh mr speaker but if he wants a further
meeting i have no doubt that the
relevant minister will be only too happy
to oblige
mr speaker i am working with incredible
stroud constituents who are dedicating
their time to helping afghan families
under threat these people are in hiding
the taliban have been going door-to-door
looking for them board options are
dangerous and constantly changing they
are absolutely terrified prime minister
will you ensure and help me uh to show
these families that they should not lose
hope and help us as mps provide timely
and credible information about safe
passage options
yes of course mr speaker and uh
my honorable friend is entirely right in
uh in what she says uh but that is why
we're going to continue to uh put all
the pressure that we can on the taliban
to ensure safe passage for the for the
groups that i have uh that i have
described and we're joined in that by
friends and partners around the world
i joined with a tribute to our armed
forces who have worked so hard there are
still people being persecuted and hunted
by the taliban because they worked for
the uk government but through
contractors not as direct employees
and they haven't had replies to their
arap applications and the rumor
circulating is that they may have to
wait for the resettlement scheme but
also
that the places on the resettlement
scheme have many of them have already
been allocated and the scheme is almost
full could he clarify the situation for
those people also tell us whether some
of the resettlement scheme places have
been pre-allocated and if so how many
and say what will be done for those
contractors as well as direct employees
who we owe an obligation to
no i'm very grateful to the right
honourable uh lady and she raises an
important question i can i can tell her
that the uh the arab places as it were
have not been transferred they continue
to be uh to be valid people on arab
scheme continue to be uh to be eligible
and uh and nor is it correct mr speaker
to say that the the initial budget of
five thousand for the resettlement
scheme has already been filled that is
not correct either well to julian
mr speaker the council for at-risk
academics has been rescuing scholars in
danger from oppressive regimes since the
nazi period in 1933.
the home office has been sent a list of
12 such scholars some of whom are in
hiding in afghanistan some in hiding in
pakistan for lack of documentation will
the home office make their case a
priority because in them lies any hope
for the future of afghanistan
yes
there are many different cases mr
speaker but uh my right honourable
friend is very uh i i thank him for
drawing attention to these uh particular
individuals who are at risk and i'll
ensure that uh the relevant foreign
office minister is in touch with him
about the specific cases that he raises
rachel
thank you mr speaker we know that the
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan and
the region is growing by the hour the
famine is expected
and of course aid is going to be
difficult to get through so what
specific steps has he taken already to
ensure that that famine is averted but
also the region receive the
international development aid it
requires in order to avert a further
crisis
i talked immediately mr speaker i think
i talked immediately uh that the crisis
broke to un secretary general antonio
guterres about what the un should be
doing what the uk
was going to do to support and
as she knows that the un continues to be
in country uh in afghanistan and we've
doubled our uh humanitarian support and
we'll be working with friends and
partners at unger and beyond to ensure
that we tackle the the humanitarian
crisis as well andrew mitchell
thank you mr speaker certainly the last
months have seen the shattering of many
illusions but
does my right honourable friend agree
that if we are tonight to help the
people of afghanistan millions of whom
are out in the open and will not be fed
we need to make sure that the whole
international community focuses on doing
so through the mechanism of the united
nations and probably through the
traditional mechanism of a regional
contact group and that britain through
its experience on these matters through
its membership of the un security
council through its g7 chairmanship is
now in a pivotal position to help those
people i mentioned
uh my right or my friend is is it
completely right to raise the the
contact group in addition to the other
forums that i have uh described and uh
to uh pay a particular note to the role
of the of the un and i know that my
rival from the foreign secretary has
just uh talked to jean arnold the uh the
un uh secretary general's special
representative uh to afghanistan uh i
think that the contact group is a vital
part of the way we should coordinate our
efforts
patricia gibson thank you mr speaker
80 percent of the world's heroin and
opium supply originates in
providing the afghanistan
with more than half its income and
causing untold misery across the world
for the future what steps is he taking
in partnership with uk allies to prevent
the taliban and the organized criminal
gangs they work with from flooding our
communities with yet more heroin given
they are now in control in afghanistan
and have fewer impediments than ever to
growing more opium
the
sadly mr speaker the
rate of production and export of heroin
of opium from uh from afghanistan has
been increasing uh in recent years and i
think the figure is actually even higher
now for in terms of global output than
the one that the uh the honourable lady
suggests and what is needed is of course
to
insist that the taliban stop this that
they don't uh allow afghanistan to
continue to be a narcos state
but the way to fight heroin consumption
uh in this country is to uh have a
strong
crime-fighting institution such as the
national uh crime agency i was
privileged to see uh the work of of our
united kingdom's uh crime fighters doing
fantastic work near glasgow
mr speaker the prime minister will be
aware that as a result of the nato
withdrawal from afghanistan there is
great concern that the terrorist threat
to this country has increased so can he
reassure the people of this country that
we maintain not only the military
capability but also the political will
to take whatever action is necessary
against groups like isis k to keep this
country safe
my honourable friend makes an extremely
important point a question that i think
a lot of people will have formed in that
in their in their minds and i know my uh
friend the defense secretary has
answered this before but of course we
keep uh those options on the table and
of course the taliban are aware of that
dave magdale
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker there are many barriers
facing people already in the immigration
system coming through one is that some
of my constituents have spouses and
children whose original documents are
with the home office and they only have
photocopies and another of course is the
english language test is he and the home
secretary proposing any movement on
those issues in order to support people
particularly those already in the system
to get here as quickly as possible yeah
yes i i thank the the right normal lady
and she should know that
of course we uh try to help people
coming from afghanistan in the most
expeditious uh way possible and i think
uh really this country cannot be faulted
for the for the generosity of our offer
on the resettlement program and it
certainly cannot be faulted mr speaker
for the sheer number of people we've
moved already uh to this country
logan
thank you very much uh mr speaker and i
welcome the prime minister's statement
aside from the g7 and traditional
partners that the prime minister
referred to in the months and years
ahead in the region in central asia
along with pakistan uzbekistan
and in particular with china what role
does he envisage these countries playing
in the geopolitics of the region
mr speaker
my friend asked
a very very important question
but i think the answer uh to that
question is it is in the interest of
every single one of the countries he has
just mentioned to ensure that
afghanistan does not relapse into the
being a breeding ground for terror uh mr
speaker does he not in china's interests
he's not in uzbekistan's intensity he's
not in russia's interest russia has
abundant experience mr speaker of the
risks of afghanistan and that's why it's
so important that we work with friends
and partners around the world and indeed
those who aren't all ordinarily
classified as our friends to achieve a
common perspective on the pressure we've
got to apply to the taliban ellen hayes
thank you mr speaker many of my
constituents have family members in
afghanistan who could be eligible for
asylum in the uk under more than one
route for example via arab or under the
foreign office special cases criteria or
under family reunion yet there is
currently no coordination between
departments my constituents are being
passed from pillar to post arap are
refusing cases where there may be an
alternative route and the foreign
secretary in the homestead because
you're not replying to their emails when
will the prime minister sort out this
lack of coordination
[Applause]
well mr speaker i must i must reject
that in the strongest possible term
because
because i want to pay i want to put this
the house the house has paid tribute
quite rightly mr speaker to the work of
the of the armed services uh over the
last uh a few few weeks a month but i
think they should also pay tribute to
the foreign common and development
office a rapid reaction team who went
out uh to afghanistan they should pay
tribute to the border force to the board
of force officials who went out there
who worked hand in glove to help
thousands of people come to this country
in safety
mark harper thank you very much uh mr
speaker in terms of protecting our
country now that the risk from
terrorists has undoubtedly increased
what is the prime minister's assessment
not just of the taliban's willingness to
deal with terrorists operating in
afghanistan but actually their
capability to deal with that terrorist
threat given what we saw from isis k
just a week or so ago
my right honourable friend is right to
uh
to draw attention to the the risks that
the taliban are themselves running
because they now possess uh the
government of afghanistan and it is
their responsibility and they clearly
face uh that threat from uh from isk
and indeed uh potentially other groups
and
of course uh they will do everything i
imagine to protect the public but uh in
the end uh mr speaker uh mr speaker we
have to face the the reality that the
taliban have now uh got the problem uh
we will do everything we can of course
to
ensure that uh
we
guard against future outbreaks of
terrorism from that country but it is in
the interest of the new government of
afghanistan to crack down on terrorism
as much as anybody else
under the nationality and borders bill
an afghan woman who flees with her
children
and arrives in britain by an irregular
route
won't be welcomed
she'll be criminalized
wales has declared our role in the world
to be as a nation of sanctuary will he
withdraw the borders bill
to enable us to fulfill our ambition
and to make that warm welcome he spoke
about yeah
no i i must i
can't accept what the our normal lady
has said because
this country has been extremely
uh
generous more generous than
most countries around the world uh not
just in bringing people immediately from
afghanistan but in setting out a safe
and and legal route uh for 20 000 more
uh to come and uh that is a a big number
uh and the the the route for those
people is clear
hey kruger
speaker uh i'm very pleased to hear
about the operation warm welcome and
wheelchair my county is home to many
thousands of british soldiers who have
served with afghan colleagues over the
last 20 years i hope the prime minister
will join me in congratulating wiltshire
council and the communities of
wheelchair including the military
communities for the welcome that they
are offering to those refugees and will
he assure the house that uh councils
across the country
will get the resources they need to
support those evacuees
yes i i thank him and of course i
congratulate uh wiltshire council for
what they are they are doing as i
congratulate all councils who are uh
stepping up to the plate and and helping
uh afghan uh afghanistan to integrate at
this time but what i can tell him is
that wheelchair council and all the
councils involved will get the support
and funding they need richard
like other members my constituency
office and i have been doing everything
we can to help constituents trapped in
afghanistan and to help their relatives
who need to get out urgently but it's
clear that the government is failing to
do all it can to help these vulnerable
people and he's disgracefully putting
even more people's lives at risk more
widely president biden has called for an
end to an era of major military
operations to remake other countries
given the huge loss of life in the
disastrous and tragic wars in iraq
afghanistan libya and elsewhere isn't it
time that we do the same
mr speaker as i've just reminded the
house the uk ended its military
operation in afghanistan in 2014.
thank you mr speaker can i ask the prime
minister what engagement he has had with
ngos which are the only western
organizations that are still on the
ground in afghanistan he and the foreign
secretary have had and what steps he
will take to protect them and can i also
ask what parameters need to be met to
see the embassy reopened the british
diplomatic network is one of the finest
in the world that is surely the way to
be able to help those who have been left
behind
honourable friend is entirely right to
uh draw attention to the incredible work
done by aid agencies by uh by ngos and
uh it's it's precisely to support
those uh
fantastic uh agencies that we've doubled
our humanitarian aid uh to afghanistan
to the region uh to 286 million pounds
this year
thank you very much mr speaker later
today i'll be reunited with an afghan
special forces commander that i had the
privilege of serving alongside he's
mightily relieved to be here but
understandably deeply concerned about
the hundreds of his men and their family
members who although approved for
relocation to the uk were left behind
what can i tell him is being done to
ensure that those who are in limbo are
afforded safe passage protection and
unimpeded access to the uk
mr speaker i i want to to pay tribute to
the service of the uh honourable
gentleman opposite and uh in addition uh
to the service of uh the afghan special
forces and he's absolutely right to draw
attention uh to uh to what they did the
uh i believe the three three three uh
the triples uh were incredibly important
and we will do uh whatever we can mr
speakers i've said uh to ensure that
those who have not yet uh come out do
get the safe passage they need johnny
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
just said from the dispatch box no
veterans call for help
will go unanswered and i totally support
that ambition in fact that was a central
aim of the establishment the office of
veterans affairs when he started
but he knows and i know that he has
consistently failed to take the measures
required to make that a reality
for veterans in communities like mine
what is he going to do differently to
make veterans feel like this change and
not just read about it in the newspapers
or hear about it from westminster
i i thank my honorable friend for the
work that he did as minister for uh for
veterans affairs and indeed for his
service uh
in in afghanistan and i i believe that
uh he underestimates what this greatly
underestimates what this country has has
done and just today on uh on uh veterans
uh mental health mr speaker the house
will have heard uh the the further
support that we're offering but this is
a government that is absolutely
determined to support our veterans and
that's why uh we passed the overseas
operations bill and will continue to
take steps to protect the veterans of
this country
thank you mr speaker i have cases
involving over 300 people who are still
stranded in afghanistan and despite
raising every case with the fcdo and the
home office i'm yet to receive a
substantial response
not one
my constituents are desperate for
information on how to travel to third
countries and when the full resettlement
scheme will be launched will the prime
minister
meet with me to discuss these urgent
cases and promise that every email will
receive a proper response from the
relevant department
i think i expect that she speaks for
many uh colleagues around the house who
who like me who have received messages
from those uh who who wish to uh to
leave afghanistan but i just repeat what
i said uh earlier on mr speaker that
every single email from our colleagues
is being responded to
by close of play today
peter burn
thank you
mr speaker like many members
i've had emails from afghan in this
country worried about their
people back in afghanistan and the home
office and the foreign office have
managed to get some of those people
relocated but i had the extraordinary
situation sir where i had an email a
very detailed email about these afghans
who have been persecuted who had worked
for the british and it was very detailed
and they produced all the documentation
then the following day my constituent
wrote to me
he said i'm really sorry
it's a complete lie
these people are taliban
and i can't go through with this
masquerade i just wonder sir
whether we should be on a guard against
getting such people into this country
uh
my honorable friend will be relieved i'm
sure like many people in this house to
to know that from the very beginning of
of pitting and uh the arap scheme and
all the subsequent schemes that we put
in place the very highest possible
security checks have been instituted to
make sure that people are who they say
they are and that we receive to this
country are the people who genuinely
deserve to come here stephen furry
mr speaker can the prime minister
clarify the current situation that
applies to those afghans who were in
this country and in our asylum system
prior to the fall of kabul will they too
be given a definite leave to remain and
surely there's no circumstances which
they would be forced to return to
afghanistan
mr speaker i'm grateful you made an
important point but many of these
individuals will already be going
through uh procedures in the in the
courts and uh we can't interrupt them uh
so those will those will go on
david davis
the whole house agreed with the prime
minister when he celebrated the heroism
of our troops
but that simply served to crystallize
that this was not so much a defeat as a
capitulation an abandonment by the west
of both people and principle yeah can i
ask the prime minister whether he
believes tony blair was right this
morning when he said the western
leadership was naive to believe that
countries could be remade
or was it that our remaking of
afghanistan needed to last longer
well if if the former if mr blatt tony
blair was saying that it was naive to
believe that countries could be remade
uh mr speaker
and he was thinking of uh
some of the things that he uh supported
then i think he was spot-on
thank you mr speaker
say to the prime minister he will re he
will know that after the kilometers
collapse of
the government in kabul the the
disorderly retreat by western powers
that there was rejoicing in parts of
mozambique across the sahel and of
course in somalia those are countries in
which we have an interest because if
nothing else they can be a source of
terrorism here what messages is is he
prepared now to give about the uk but
about the uk working with partners to
guarantee that there is a proper
response a a measured response that will
make sure that we are not at risk of
terrorism
mr speaker the honorable gentleman is
focusing on exactly the right uh
question and on exactly the right
response from uh the western world and
indeed the whole global community we
need to work together to ensure that as
far as we possibly can
we condition the new government new
authorities in kabul to understand that
afghanistan can't just slide back into
being a cesspit of terror and that's
what that's our our effort today
richard
thank you mr speaker many lessons will
have been learned and re-learned from
afghanistan not least the need for boots
on the ground
with the u.s becoming more isolated will
my right on my friend look again at the
disastrous plan to reduce the army by 10
000.
mr speaker we are very proud of what
we've done uh since this government came
in to increase the size of our defence
commitments to the the biggest uh
by the biggest amount since the end of
the uh of the cold war and uh
on his point about uh afghanistan i
think that the reality is that even when
there were 130 000 uh western troops in
afghanistan it was not possible to
subjugate
the the taliban and uh i i'm afraid that
we're living with the lessons of that
today
thank you very much mr speaker
last friday through tears a young afghan
constituent told me how his father a
british citizen
was turned away from the baron hotel in
kabul on the 28th of august his father
was trying to evacuate his other
children but he was refused permission
to take two of them out of the country
because they were aged 18 and 19. can
the prime minister imagine the pain of
that kind of family separation so all of
them have stayed in car but at huge risk
to themselves will he look again at the
rules of family reunification and
finally make it possible for for
families to stay together and not to
have to to face this terrible terrible
choice
uh well mr speaker i know the whole
house will be full of sympathy to the
family that uh that she describes in the
uh the heartbreak that they they must
have felt and i'm sure there are many
many cases in
in in kabul uh right now uh but i think
that the record of this country and
receiving people and being prepared to
receive people in the future is very
good and can i ask that in the
particular particular uh family that
she's talking about uh can i ask her
police to to write to me or to the home
secretary directly caroline notes
many constituents have understandably
been in touch desperately worried about
family members in afghanistan they want
to find out whether the afghan citizen
resettlement scheme will be an
application or an allocation process
when it will open and what that process
will look like
i i thank the uh
uh right honorable lady we'll be making
sure that the uh
there is a process by which people can
apply uh but there is clearly a uh a a
ceiling in the first year of 5000 then
it goes up to uh 20 000 over the next
few years
john charlie
and christians in afghanistan are one of
the many minorities facing
persecution and many have been forced to
flee their homes
a church community in my constituency is
working around the clock to support
several christian families to flee to
pakistan
and to seek asylum at the embassy of a
safe third country they're not looking
for asylum in the uk but they're looking
to get to pakistan so what particular
support
will his government offer vulnerable
christians such as those that the
community in my constituency are working
with and to which department should i
direct my entreaties in the hope of
actually getting an answer
i i thank the the community the church
community that she describes for the
work that they are uh they are doing and
uh in in moving people to uh pakistan uh
the
government is is helping by increasing
the funding available and uh
much of which obviously already goes uh
to pakistan and that's the the purpose
of the uh the increase in the in the aid
budget this year
liam fox
even if we believe that the whole
afghanistan withdrawal was a us-made
policy that was ill-judged and poorly
executed can i ask my right honourable
friend to reject those voices calling
for the united kingdom to pull back from
the united states and seek alternative
alliances elsewhere truly the right
response is to stick closely to our u.s
friends remind them that an era of
globalization our economic and security
interests will be threatened beyond our
borders that the united states is a
force for good in the world and that
greater isolationism can only put us all
in greater danger
mr speaker we helped 36 countries to
repatriate their nationals or those that
they had helped but we could not have
done it mr speaker had it not been for
the bravery of the u.s military and the
commitment of the u.s military and i
passionately agree with what he has just
said about the fundamental importance of
our alliance with the united states of
america imran jose
thank you mr speaker the
government leaving vulnerable afghans
and british nationals behind
is unforgivable
but what is completely
and utterly
reprehensible is that the families of
two of my constituents
including a seven month old child
were forcibly removed from flights
and thrown out of kabul airport onto the
streets where the scene of the horrific
suicide bombing hours before
mr speaker
i am absolutely furious and i want to
ask the prime minister
how on earth was this potentially fatal
decision allowed to happen even after i
raised these matters with ministers
satwist left and israel and how many
others were ejected from the airport
into harm's way and just what does he
have to say
to the families that the government has
now put
in grave danger
i i thank him very much mr speaker for
raising the the case i i have to tell
him that uh i'm told we have no evidence
of anybody being pulled off uh flight
but i would ask him
obviously mr speaker i would ask him to
uh to raise it with uh raise the
particular cases directly with uh with
my right honourable uh friends uh beside
me uh but i can tell him i i think that
when he looks at the overall record of
the uk and moving people out of kabul uh
and across the whole of afghanistan it
was an astonishing feat
ian duncan
mr speaker i thank my right friend for
his statement can i ask
can i ask whether or not he's noticed
that the chinese government since our
departure from afghanistan has used
afghanistan to up its threats on taiwan
with hundreds of overflights threatening
them and telling them when the war comes
the us will not be there to support them
could my brother friend take this
opportunity from the dispatch box to say
to the taiwanese and others we fully
support their right to democracy
self-determination and we will be there
to support them no matter what the
chinese say and could we persuade the
americans to do the same yeah yeah yeah
mr speaker i i thank my right honourable
friend and
i'm
of course aware of the continuing uh
issues between the people's republic of
china and uh and taiwan uh and we i've
discussed that indeed recently with uh
with the president of the of the united
states and uh it's one of the reasons
why it's absolutely vital uh that this
country continues to uh insist on the
primacy of uh our relationship with the
united states and uh of the uh the
situation in taiwan will continue to be
difficult and under the house should
shall understand it will the only answer
the only way forward is to continue to
support american global leadership and
that is what we will do
thank you mr speaker
as the prime minister knows ngos such as
the excellent kent refugee action
network provide vital support to those
fleeing from conflict and as you
mentioned that's via fundraising but
does he also acknowledge that the state
has a duty of care regarding the mental
health of traumatized refugees including
children and if he does
how can he assure the house that this
will be possible given that the average
weight for young people waiting just a
basic mental health assessment is on
average two to three years currently
[Music]
i i i thank her but i can tell her that
the the government is absolutely
determined uh to uh look after people
coming from afghanistan and in
particular uh look after their mental
health or the trauma that they have uh
suffered and that's that's uh why we are
investing uh massively in the services
that are being provided not just by uh
by clg but uh by by uh by local
government across the board
can i ask the prime minister please what
extra funds are going to be made
available for local councils and schools
like the derbyshire dales district
council who urgently want to help but
want to make sure there are funds
additional funds available
i thank i thank her and i thank
derbyshire dale's uh district council
for uh for stepping up mr speaker and
yes of course we will make sure that the
funds are available and she should uh
make representations to uh my older
friend member for life in horn castle
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's handling of the plan
departure from afghanistan for those of
us who are old enough in here is akin to
one of the farcical characters and
carrying up the kaiba
foreign secretary was on a beach as the
taliban advanced in kabul unknown
numbers of british nationals remain left
behind and the taliban and most probably
isis have been allowed to plunder
military hardware and intelligence
does the prime minister accept any
responsibility any personal
responsibility for the message being
left in afghanistan and does he agree
that any notion of global britain is in
complete crisis
uh no mr speaker and uh he should he
should not he's wrong in every respect
including by the way mr speaker he's
wrong in what he says about
military hardware because that was
decommissioned
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has said we should judge the taliban by
their actions not their words the
taliban in afghanistan have said they
will confine and operate within the
rules of islam as somebody who comes
from a muslim background whose father is
an imam whose grandfather is in imam
whose uncles were imams i'm not an
expert on islam i have a good
understanding of the faith a way forward
for the prime minister and government
may be this if the prime minister were
to use his kind offices and ask the oic
the organization of islamic corporation
57 member states who to ask the other
leading islamic school of thought to to
set out what it means with regards to
and what's that what islam stands for
for women and religious minorities and
that may give us a way to judge to see
what the taliban are doing and what
islam stands for prime minister
i think my honorable friend is making a
very interesting suggestion and i i i
hope that uh it will be uh i hope it
will encourage it to be to be taken up
but uh what we need to do is to make
sure that those elements of the of the
taliban who are different and i believe
they are who are different from the
taliban of 1996 are encouraged and that
we put the maximum pressure on them not
to allow the uh the more
retrograde elements to have the upper
hand and that is that is uh what this
government and other governments around
the world are going to do
ribbon
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
many communities the city of leeds
included have always given a very warm
welcome
to refugees but we know
that the poorest parts of our country
have consistently taken a much higher
proportion
of refugees and asylum seekers than the
wealthier areas
does the prime minister think that is
fair and if not what does he intend to
do about it
prime minister
mr speaker i believe the whole country
should pull together and everybody
should uh step up to the plate and i
know the there are councils across the
country uh that will want to help and
are helping i thank the people of leeds
uh very much what they've done both now
and historically and i hope that uh
councils around the world will follow
their example around around the uk i
will follow their example
can i thank my right honourable friend
for his statement
in which he refers to the fact that
saturday is the 20th anniversary of 9
11.
and given that public confidence has
taken
quite a bashing from this episode in the
government's strategic thinking is it
not now time for a cold hard strategic
look
at how well we have done over the last
20 years what has gone well the mistakes
we have made
what we have learned and what should be
implemented to to implement those
lessons will he undertake to make sure
that reflection takes place prime
minister
yes i i'm grateful to uh my right
honourable friend i i think the best i
can
do is direct him once again to the
integrated review which i know that he
has studied and i believe uh is now more
relevant than ever
jim shot
i thank the the prime minister for a
statement today
is the prime minister aware there is a
desire within industry to help provide
refugees with housing and jobs two firms
from michigan say for instance one of
the fruits and master direct are very
keen and willing to give the jobs to the
afghanis and also have the the access to
private housing goodness always shines
through prime minister and i think
that's something we should always
remember what steps can the prime
minister give via the treasury to help
assist and incentivize firms who want to
help those who served alongside british
forces and whose lives are at risk for
their commitment to freedom and
democracy in afghanistan thank you prime
minister uh mr speaker the honourable
general makes an incredibly important
point because the labour market is is is
full of uh vacancies at the at the
moment and there is a there is a there
are obviously opportunities uh for for
hard-working people uh of talent and
energy to uh come and make their lives
across the whole of the of the uk and we
will help them uh with uh with training
uh with the english language and as i've
been saying with uh what else they need
in stark contrast with the leader of the
opposition whose definition of
leadership seems to be silence followed
by 2020 hindsight i commend the prime
minister for his leadership in this
crisis and i ask him to continue that
both on behalf of the uk
and the g7 for women and girls in
afghanistan both for their education
and for their wider participation in
afghan society
well i i thank my honorable friend and i
think i i and i have to say i think that
the
the uk uh together with uh with our
german friends our italian friends our
french friends our american friends are
pulling together with all our our g7 uh
colleagues and others are pulling
together to forge a collective uh global
uh view as far as we possibly can about
how to deal uh with the new regime in
kabul and it's by working together that
we will get the best results in the uk
as as the house the whole house knows uh
is in pole position in all the key
institutions and we will continue to
exercise that role
jeremy corbyn
i realize the government's focus at the
moment is on refugees in dealing with
the immediate crisis but does he not
think that with tens of thousands of
afghan dead thousands of american dead
hundreds of british dead it is time for
a full inquiry into the whole process
that led us into afghanistan and the
whole notion of a foreign policy in
which we intervene all over the world
and start to re-examine our place and
our role in this world
prime minister the right honourable
gentleman knows because he's heard me
say it before that there was a full uh
review after the extraction after the
end of the military operation
in 2014 a review of what it achieved and
the uh the the legacy of those brave uh
british men and women who served uh in
afghanistan i think that was the right
uh the right thing to do as for the rest
i i don't know whether he's read uh the
integrated review uh from cover to cover
uh mr speaker uh but i i direct him to
it
following our ignominious withdrawal
from afghanistan where effectively were
dragged out on the coattails of our more
powerful american allies the world has
changed mr speaker and the world has
become a more dangerous place would my
right honourable friend share with the
house his latest assessment of the
so-called special relationship and isn't
it time for another defense review
administrator
i i i thank my uh honorable friend and
his uh
his trench and views uh uh i often agree
with but i think i think in this case
the special relationship is is is
basically mr speaker i think i i
recorded the car this play the
irreplaceable or the indestructible race
i can't remember exactly what phrase i
use but that is what it is it is a basic
geopolitical fact not on the special
relationship rests much of the security
of the last 100 years and it will
continue to be of cardinal importance to
this country and that is a fact that is
as understood in washington as it is in
this country it's kyle
the prime minister has turned his back
on the eu the washington has turned its
back on him can you tell us since he
became prime minister and stood on a
platform of global britain where does
britain have more influence than when
before he became prime
the prime minister i'm delighted to say
mr speaker that uh thanks to virtually
everywhere is the answer to that uh mr
speaker uh but but but across the across
the because because we are able uh we we
not only have we have our own sanctions
policy mr speaker uh we are a but we've
been able to set up embassies and
legations new ones around the world in
uh in the in the south pacific in africa
uh we are we are opening up mr speaker
and mr speaker we are doing free trade
deals i think a total of 63
so far mr speaker and who knows maybe
there'll be an even maybe there'll even
be another one this week mr speaker
[Music]
thank you mr speaker as the prime
minister will be aware that the majority
of people who came to this country from
afghanistan came by a birmingham airport
to my constituency will my right on a
friend join me in commending the team at
birmingham airport sully hall council
third sector organizations like and
trader three three trees community
center who welcome nearly a thousand
people a day and sometimes many many
children and young babies
prime minister
yes mr speaker i had the the opportunity
to thank the the troops uh the other day
but i i want to thank everybody who's
been involved the the uh the the the
border force officials everybody uh in
the councils uh who have been at the
front line of dealing with this this
crisis i think they've done it with
exceptional humanity and compassion
thank you mr speaker i've sent 143
afghans who are connected with my
constituency through to the foreign
secretary and to the defense secretary
and their home secretary i've got them
on the wrong order but anyway all three
of them because there are three
different um
channels can i just reflect get urged
the prime minister to reflect on the
idea that was has been suggested by
countless colleagues on this side that
there should be a single triage point a
single person that deals with all of
these because since i sent in those
names
one of them has been shot
one has been raped and one has been
tortured
so people are desperate to try and get
the best result for these people i'm
sure the ministers want to help but at
the moment it just feels as if the left
hand doesn't know what the right hand is
doing
mr speaker i'm sure the whole house
sympathizes very much with what's
happened to uh the individuals that he
describes in uh in afghanistan and we
are doing our level best to help people
as fast as we can uh i want the uh
government to uh to focus uh on uh on
helping people with a single point of a
single point of control that's why uh my
honourable friend the member for life
and horn castle is is the is the person
in question mr clarks
thank you mr speaker the men and women
who serve in our armed forces are
remarkable and make huge sacrifices both
personally and in their careers uh can
my roger my friend the prime minister um
confirmed that we they're going to get
the very best of support and care when
they return home so that they know this
nation is grateful for what they've done
prime minister
yes mr speaker it's absolutely vital
that those who have
given so much who serve so bravely
in afghanistan and indeed their families
should receive the lifelong support that
they deserve and they will mr speaker
jessica
thank you very much my office and i have
been trying for several years through
the home office to reunite various
afghan interpreters who settled in
newport with their wives and families
and just hours before
before the withdrawal their paperwork
came through but they weren't able to
get through the crowds to flights we
understand they're not eligible for arab
so does that mean they are included in
the resettlement scheme and what happens
now given the principle of them joining
their husbands has been agreed yeah
i'm very grateful i'm very sorry to hear
what uh what happened at uh to at
handcastle international airport uh i
hope that they will be uh successful
under the uh the resettlement scheme and
if she'd be kind enough to send details
through uh to the home secretary i'd be
very grateful jameson
mr speaker it's very easy of course to
apportion blame with the benefit of
hindsight but this is a really complex
environment and the current situation is
as much a failure of leadership in
afghanistan as anything else
whilst we may not want to engage with
the taliban does the prime minister
agree that we have no choice but to do
so and perhaps with a forward presence
in kabul in the same way that our
chinese and russian adversaries have
prime minister
uh mr speaker i may say so the the my
honourable friend is is very wise in
what he says i believe that it is
inevitable for us uh to engage with the
taliban
and indeed we have been we are
at the airport uh you british uh troops
were working directly with their taliban
uh counterparts to ensure that the
operation uh went through and that was
an inevitability uh mr speaker and
we will of course uh look at further
cooperation but as i said to the house
we will judge the new uh regime in kabul
uh not by what they say but by what they
do right now yeah yeah
mr speaker our trips did a great job at
kabul airport but it's also the case
that events of recent weeks
have exposed the limitations of our
ability to act out with the umbrella of
the united states even if we wanted to
choose a different path
what is the prime minister's response to
the exposure of those limitations
prime minister i i don't agree with uh
with what he said because i think that
the
the particular case of of afghanistan
was one in which america was but was
very much engaged because of 911. uh it
was america that supplied uh 98 percent
of the uh of the air power the munitions
dropped 98
were from uh were from from the us it
was overwhelmingly a u.s led mission uh
but that doesn't mean uh that the uk
cannot cooperate and will not cooperate
with other friends and partners around
the world that is what we're going to
continue to do that's right
167 occasions all told i stood with the
people of what's now royalton bassett to
see 345 of our comrades repatriated to
this country on no occasion did i hear
anybody say why did nobody ever said
these lives were wasted nobody was ever
ashamed or or
what happened on the contrary they were
proud of the fact these young people
have given their lives for the service
of their country and for the benefit of
the people of afghanistan and for the
security of the world the prime minister
agreed with me that should now be the
litmus test as to how we judge what's
happening in afghanistan we should be
proud of what we've done yeah prime
minister i thank my ronald friend i
believe he speaks for millions of people
quiet people up and down this country
yes
prime minister will be aware that the
entire house
is united in offering our respect and
our congratulations to the people at the
grassroots who made
that
evacuation of british passport holders
and afghans possible in recent weeks but
the prime minister must also be aware
how difficult it has been to get
responses from government departments on
behalf of our constituents who are
terrified about their relatives and want
to arrange for safe passage for their
relatives will the government give the
house an undertaking that he will make
sure that the relevant government
department have the resources have the
people so we are able to communicate
with our constituents and give them some
news at least prime minister
i i thank her and she's she's really
repeating a point that's been made uh up
and down uh across the house by uh by
many colleagues this afternoon uh but i
think that the the work so far has been
uh extraordinary i pay tribute to the
speed with which uh british officials
have done their best to to respond and
every email as i've said mr speaker will
be answered by tonight
there's some did get in and hopefully we
can pick those up in the next statement
from the foreign secretary call the
foreign secretary
go ahead
mr speaker with your permission i will
update the house on the uk's
international response to the situation
in afghanistan
as my right honourable friend the prime
minister has set out over the last three
weeks through shared effort right across
government and our armed forces we have
delivered the largest and most complex
evacuation in living memory
between the 15th and the 29th of august
the uk evacuated over 15 000 people from
afghanistan that includes over 8
thousand british nationals uh close to
five thousand afghan law afghans who
loyally serve the uk along with uh with
their dependents
and around 500 special cases of
particularly vulnerable afghans
including achieving scholars journalists
human rights defenders campaigners for
women's rights judges and many others
of course the work to get people out
didn't start on the 15th of august the
scdo advised british nationals to leave
the country in april and then again on
the 6th of august we estimate that
around 500 did so
at the same time the government launched
the arap scheme for interpreters and
other afghan staff getting over 1 900
out before the airlift began on the 15th
of august
now as the the security situation
deteriorated we accelerated that process
throughout july and early august in
total since april we've helped over 17
000 people leave and i want to place on
on record my thanks and pay tribute to
the herculean efforts of our troops our
diplomats our civil servants who have
done an incredible job in the toughest
of conditions and as we remember
their efforts we also remember
those
of uk armed forces who paid the ultimate
sacrifice in afghanistan trying to make
that country a better place for the
afghan people
mr speaker now that the evacuation has
ended we have moved into a new phase
we stand by our commitment to support
those who have worked for us and to take
all remaining eligible cases
securing their safe passage out of the
country
is an immediate priority
we're working through our diplomatic
channels to that end
and of course the taliban have given
assurances that they will provide safe
passage for foreign nationals and those
eligible afghans who wish to leave
so on the 30th of august the un security
council passed resolution
2593 driven by the uk alongside the us
and france affirming the international
community's expectation requirement that
the taliban should follow through on the
assurances that they've given
last week i visited qatar and pakistan
in qatar i met with yami and their
deputy prime minister and foreign
minister sheikh mohammed to discuss safe
passage alongside the international
community's wider approach to dealing
with the taliban
we discussed ongoing efforts to
re-establish flights at kabul airport
where qatari technical staff are working
on the ground and see how we can
cooperate in handling the organization
of future flights
i also announced our new non-resident
chaje de faire for afghanistan martin
longdon who is now working out of doha
in pakistan i met with prime minister
khan and foreign minister qureshi to
discuss safe passage for our third
countries and the importance of holding
the taliban to its commitments
i also announced that we're sending 30
million pounds of support to
afghanistan's neighbours
this will provide life-saving support
for refugees including shelters
household necessities sanitation and
other hygiene facilities
the same time i dispatched last week a
new rapid deployment team to the region
with an extra 22 staff in total
they will reinforce our embassy teams
our high commission teams in those
neighboring countries processing british
nationals or eligible eligible afghans
who are seeking to leave our third
countries which we want to do just as
fast as we possibly can once they can
leave and subject to the necessary
security checks
i also spoke to the foreign minister of
uzbekistan earlier today the foreign
minister of tajikistan last week and the
minister for south asia lord ahmed last
week visited tajikistan and will return
to the region shortly
mr speaker turning to the wider
international strategy the international
community is adjusting and it must
adjust to the new reality in afghanistan
and recalibrate its approach
the uk is playing a leading role my
right honourable friend the prime
minister convened g7 leaders on the 24th
of august 24th of august forgive me to
discuss a shared response to the
situation
that followed a g7 foreign minister's
meeting and we are building a global
coalition around four key priorities set
out in a uk g7 paper that we've shared
with those partners first
we must prevent afghanistan from ever
becoming a safe haven or harbour for
terrorists ever again
second we must prevent a humanitarian
disaster and support refugees wherever
possible
in the region
the uk has allocated
286 million pounds in aid for
afghanistan this year
we're supporting afghanistan's
neighbours as i've already set out and
the home secretary has set out our
resettlement scheme
so we are leading by example which
enables us to encourage others to step
up in what will inevitably have to be an
international team effort
third we must preserve regional
stability which risks being shattered by
the combination of renewed terrorist
threat and an exodus of refugees fourth
we must hold the taliban and other
factions to account for their conduct
including in particular on human rights
and their treatment of women and girls
i'm taking this forward through our
bilateral partners we have a g7 plus
meeting later this week and the uk is
also pressing for further discussions
amongst the permanent members of the un
security council we plan to host an
event at the un general assembly later
this month as indicated by the prime
minister
mr speaker
we will not recognize the taliban but we
will engage and we will carefully
calibrate our actions to the choices
that they make and the actions that they
take
given our strategic priorities the ones
that i've set out we must also set some
credible tests
to hold the taliban to the undertakings
they have made on safe passage on
terrorism on humanitarian access and a
more inclusive government
and we stand ready to use all the levers
at our disposal in that effort political
economic and diplomatic
mr speaker
we continue to galvanize the
international community and bring
together the widest possible group of
influential countries to deliver on
those strategic priorities and exercise
the maximum moderating influence on the
taliban that we possibly can and i
commend the state of the house
let's call shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandi mr speaker this has been a painful
and sobering few weeks and were it not
for the heroic efforts of the armed
forces as well as the brave diplomats
and civil servants involved in operation
pitting many more lives would have been
lost and many more left behind they
reminded us what courage looks like and
i would like to put on record my thanks
to them to all of those who've served in
afghanistan over the last two decades
and to add my condolences to the
families of all those killed in the
horrific bombing at kabul airport but if
more lives are not to be lost we need
some urgent clarity today what
specifically is the advice to people
trying to leave should they stay put and
be hunted by the taliban or should they
make their way to a border and risk
being turned back could the foreign
secretary take care of some basic issues
the home office phone number provided to
afghans asked people to hold for hours
and it's still chargeable this is
pretty easy to fix could he have a word
with the home secretary and get it dealt
with he wasn't able to tell us how many
british nationals are still there but i
imagine he must know by now so can he
tell us
we know that only one security guard
from the embassy got out so what is his
plan for the rest i did a quick check
before i left my office today there are
still hundreds of unanswered emails from
mps and many of them have raised that
with the prime minister today how many
staff are now working on this in the
foreign office and why hasn't it been
dealt with if they're to get an answer
by this evening can he assure us that
that will be a real answer and not just
a holding response and can we have some
clarity about who is actually eligible
particularly under the arab scheme and
it's welcome that the defense secretary
has stayed for this
statement without clarity about who is
eligible people can't risk heading to
the border so the special cases in
particular would be really useful to
have a much tighter idea of who they are
what is the assurance about safe passage
that he believes he has from the taliban
does it apply to all those with
documentation or just the british
nationals
i understand that the technical problems
at the airport have now been overcome
and that is welcome but can you tell us
a bit more about the diplomatic progress
that has been made how for example does
he intend to square the circle
to comply with the taliban's refusal to
allow a foreign military presence but to
safeguard those technicians from turkey
or qatar or whichever
other country is chosen to oversee that
operation in order to make sure that
they can be safeguarded i very much
support his view that it would be wrong
to recognise the taliban as a legitimate
government but this also presents a
practical challenge to those countries
that are considering stepping in to
oversee the airport about how guarantees
can be upheld
can i just say to him that the
coordination between the foreign office
and the ministry of defense despite some
very hard-working civil servants on the
ground who are working round the clock
is still appalling
my office is in touch with a small
number of afghan workers for example who
are attached to intelligence and to mi6
in recent years they're being treated as
special cases under arab and many of
them have been waiting for months i
would like to place on record my thanks
to the secretary of state for defence
and also for the mint to the minister
for afghanistan who've made themselves
available to many of us at all hours in
short notice to assist with some of
these cases their personal intervention
has made a difference but this is no
substitute for a system
could he also clear up some comments
that he made at the select committee he
suggested that those who've been cleared
to travel as part of operation pitting
would now have to undergo security
checks before
they were accepted onto arab were those
checks not initially done or is he now
reneging on his promise i have to say
that both of those scenarios concern us
greatly mr speaker these are practical
issues that are within his gift and the
fact that they still haven't been dealt
with sends a strong message that he's
been more focused in recent days on
keeping his job than actually doing it i
want him to prove us wrong because a lot
rides on this including the lives of
many afghans who assisted us could i
also ask him to say a bit more about how
the uk is going to get aid into
afghanistan to those who need it i've
been in touch with aid workers on the
ground many of them female who've been
banned from working by the taliban those
aid agencies of course are
understandably saying they won't operate
with those conditions in place but that
means they're not
operating at all and on the refugee
crisis can i just say to him gently that
countries in the region are not hugely
impressed by the decision by the home
secretary to cap the number of refugees
that the uk will accept at 5 000 when
they're dealing with a far greater
refugee crisis a bit of generosity from
the uk would go a long way to helping to
resolve the issues at the borders mr
speaker these are immediate concerns but
we are also concerned that for a
generation of young afghans the future
that they'd expected is unravelling in
front of their eyes can he say something
about the lgbt right plus community and
how their rights will be upholded as
we're all upheld as well as religious
minorities can he outline the measures
that he intends to take to um to set
conditions for the taliban regime and
particularly that the situation of women
and girls will be the cornerstone of any
future engagement and finally mr speaker
can i just say that our intelligence has
been downgraded our diplomats and troops
are now longer on the ground and the
prime minister appeared to say in the
statement just now that the risk that is
posed to the uk is unknown he suggested
in a media interview that we would rely
on open source intelligence could he say
some more about that and also that we
might be in a position where we were
sharing intelligence with countries like
china and russia given the significant
national security implications of this
the house has a right to understand what
the government's strategy is on this if
there is one this has been nothing short
of a disaster mr speaker so can i ask
him now to turn with humility
to the world and start to repair some of
those broken relationships those trashed
alliances those broken promises that
have reduced us to a position where
we're relying on the taliban for
permission to safeguard our own citizens
and negotiating with china and russia in
our own interests in the cold hard light
of what has unfolded over this summer
surely it is time for him to rethink his
approach to the way that britain engages
with the rest of the world yeah foreign
secretary can i thank the honourable
lady for what she said about the efforts
of our uk forces and i believe also the
cross whitehall teams who've delivered
the biggest evacuation in living memory
and she asked for specific advice she'll
understand i'm a bit reticent about
giving uh personal advice to generically
but the travel advice that the sejo
putting out is very clear and it has
been changed to reflect um the situation
on the ground and i think that is the
right point of reference of
constituents of honourable members
around the house she asked about
telephone phone calls into the scdo
crisis center since the 11th of august
it's handled more than 44 000 calls
we searched 45 members of scdo staff and
35 staff from other departments
since the 19th of august we've answered
uh well over 90 93
of the total number received um and and
every day since the 24th our call
handlers have answered more than 94 of
the calls that were made and just to
give the honourable lady a sense since
the 20th of august average wait times
have been less than a minute
she also asked um uh about
correspondence uh as my right honourable
friend the prime minister made clear we
will have sent to reply to all mps
emails asking for an update by the 30th
um
uh emails that we receive by the 30th of
august we will reply to all of them
today that will be to enable
to signpost them uh to the specific
advice relevant to the particular case
that they're raising
the
we will also respond to
[Music]
all the other emails that we've received
by members of the public she made some
points and a couple honourable members
have made this point
certainly on on her side about putting
them all in together these are different
cases the eligibility for nationality is
different from the resettlement scheme
which is different from our app and so
it's right that they are triaged to the
proper decision maker and that's the
point of the exercise that we're engaged
in um
in relation to arabs she asked about the
details that the arab scheme is
published um so the details are there
well if she's if she's concerned about
any particular aspects and of course she
should have approached the relevant uh
minister she asked about safe passage
and and and how and how well we can't
answer the questions john honorable lady
in abstract
in order to give effect to the
circumstances of the cases she's
referring to she asked about safe
passage the taliban has given us an
assurance that those nationals
and those that worked for us who want to
leave will be allowed to leave but like
a range of other commitments that
they've made uh we'll have to hold them
uh we'll have these will form one of the
early tests for the taliban and they
will be judged by what they do
rather than just what they say but that
was the reason that we passed and she
talks about influence we led with the
french and the americans the u.n
security council resolution which
reiterated and affirmed and applied the
international communities in premature
on that demand of the taliban we'll now
have to see whether they can pass that
test she mentioned kabul airport
kabul airport is not up and running yet
um but uh there are efforts on going to
deal with not only the operational
capacity the technical capacity but also
the security conditions um and and i
think for uh most cases whether they're
british nationals arab or uh special
cases indeed on the resettlement scheme
the the most straightforward way would
be if we can safely get uh seekable
airport up and running if not we'll have
to look at third party third country
routes out but of course many of the
third countries in the region are very
nervous we've had conversations with all
of them that was why i was in qatar
pakistan to look at the arrangements the
practical arrangements uh for how we
would um
deliver on it
she asked about security checks of
course
we will make sure that in relation to uh
those wanting to come to the uk that not
only do we check the eligibility so that
the seats on planes are going to those
who we want to come who are eligible to
come who we need to come
and also to make sure the security
checks are in place
to avoid the wrong kind of people coming
back to the uk
she also asked about aiden to
afghanistan and how we can ensure it
gets to where it needs to go
we've provided and i announced last week
30 million pounds for neighbouring
countries to deal with refugees in the
region precisely because
it is better for refugees to be dealt
with closer to
their home but also because we do
recognize the burden that we place on
the region um in relation to aid more
generally and the rest of the 286
million of course this is another of the
early tests for the taliban because we
will not give aid to the taliban
therefore if they want to avoid the
social and economic fabric of the
country collapsing if they want the aid
to continue to flow they will need to
provide a safe operating environment for
the un
and other agencies and i spoke to the uh
secretary um secretary general's special
envoy um jean know precisely about that
uh we've got further meetings this week
with uh g7 plus um i will have further
conversations i'm sure i'll be traveling
uh to the region uh the uk has been uh
has issued a g7 paper which sets out the
key priorities from counter-terrorism to
the humanitarian lifeline it's been very
well received we've now got to do
working with our partners is
operationalize it she asked about some
of the non-g7 partners the reality is if
we want to influence in the most
effective way possible the taliban we
need a broader caucus particularly
regional countries particularly those uh
who
also have a relationship with the
taliban to exercise the maximum the
maximum moderating influence on the
taliban that's just what we do
snp spokesperson alan smith
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm also
grateful for advanced site of the
statement and i have to say on behalf of
my group that uh the impression we've
been given about ministerial
communications with members of this
house in constituency cases is not as
rosy as has been put forward by
government ministers and i would
constructively suggest that there needs
to be a proper review of